la déclaration de olivier servas un
député de la guadeloupe qui mercredi
dernier sur une radio en guadeloupe a
annoncé qu'il allait débuter un
recensement de tous les travailleurs
d'école en martinique et en guadeloupe
qui ont eu à travailler avec le
chlordécone et qu'un fonds
d'indemnisation a été mis en place en
tout cas sera créé pour toutes ces
personnes qui pourraient un jour être
indemnisé pourquoi est ce que vous
n'avez pas communiquer sur 7 sur cette
nouvelle qui est très importante puisque
vous même vous êtes aussi d'éviter je
communique surtout pour dire que ce qui
nous est présenté est une farce c'est à
dire que ce que dit olivier servat c'est
pas vrai je ne suis pas sur libé servat
pour l'instant je suis sur ce qui est
proposé
il n'y a aucun fond de proposer pour
indemniser les 750 mille personnes
touchées par la chlordécone et
conviennent chauve souris c'est que
quand monsieur olivier servent a dit
qu'on peut lui envoyer des dossiers
parce qu'on est prêt mais il a dit ça y
est ça me semble très surprenant mais
même dangereux pour lui parce que on
sait que des procédures d'indemnisation
il ya des commissions il ya des enjeux
techniques d ordre juridique il ya des
enjeux scientifiques et comme l'idée de
monsieur macro in fine et par rapport à
ce qu'il avait déclaré à la martinique
en septembre ce n'est que trouver une
solution pour ouvrir en tant que maladie
professionnelle une indemnisation pour
les ouvriers agricoles dont qui ne fait
que quelque chose d'extrêmement
restreint c'est utile pour les ou
agricole mais il ne répond pas à
l'ampleur du dégâts qui ont été causés